British Prime Minister Theresa May has faced
heavy opposition in parliament, after delivering
a statement on her government's draft agreement
on post-Brexit relations with Brussels.
Opposition leader Jeremy Corby said the deal
represents "the worst of all worlds."
The UK and European Union appear to have settled
their differences over Brexit.
Disputes over fishing rights, Gibraltar and
the border between Britain and Ireland are
still to be resolved.
But EU leaders say they're reached agreement
in principle.
British prime minister Theresa May is under
intense pressure from political opponents
at home, but says she's confident British
lawmakers will approve the deal.
They’re not exactly celebrating, but EU
leaders including chief Brexit negotiator
Jean-Michel Barnier have at least one reason
to be cheerful.
The draft agreement on the UK's withdrawal
from the bloc should be signed off at a summit
in Brussels on Sunday.
British prime minister Theresa May told parliament
in London it was a
good deal for Britain.
It honours the vote of the British people
by taking back control of our borders, our
laws and our money, while protecting jobs,
security and the integrity of our precious
United Kingdom.
It ends free movement once and
for all.
We will make our own laws in our own parliaments.
And it means an end to sending vast sums of
money to the EU."
Opposition leader Jeremy Corby was far from
convinced.
The prime minister said nothing is agreed
until everything is agreed.
It's clear from this document that nothing
is agreed.
This is the blindfold Brexit we all feared,
a leap in the dark.
German Chancellor Angela Merkel had threatened
to boycott Sunday's summit unless everything
was hammered out in advance.
She now seems to be on board.
I will do everything possible to get an exit
agreement.
A disorderly Brexit is the worst possible
thing, not just for the economy but for our
future relationship.
Also today, prime minister May had what she
said was a friendly chat with the Austrian
Chancellor Sebastian Kurz.
Getting the Brexit deal through her own parliament
will be an altogether more hostile process.